الردود والفعل لتتواصل حول الفوز التاريخي
للمنتخب السعودي المغرب ينتزع النقطه
ثمينه من اولى مبارياته بكاس العالم تصميم
ساعه رونالدو يثير غضبا لدى جماهير
مانشستر يونايتد هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
ما زالت الوصول المتعلقه بفوز المنتخب
السعودي على نظيره الارجنتيني تتصدر
التراند في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي خصوصا
تويتر وحديث وسائل الاعلام
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان للاعبي
الاخضر قبل اسابيع اذا طلب منهم ان يكونوا
مرتاحين وان يستنفعوا بالبطوله فيما قال
ايرفيرينار مدرب المنتخب السعودي الا
توجيهات ولي العهد وعدم ممارساته اي ضغوط
على اللاعبين كان له اثر كبير في تحقيق
الفوز على تانجو بهدفين لهدف في اولى
مباريات المجموعه الثالثه بكاس العالم
وعلى الوصول الاكثر تداولا نشر ناشطون قصص
طريفه حول احداث المباراه التاريخيه ومنها
خساره رجل استرالي لنحو 160 الف دولار
بسبب هزيمه الارجنتين صحيفه ديلي ميلي
البريطانيه كشفت ان الرجل كان قد راهن
بهذا المبلغ الضخم على فوز التانجو بقياده
ليونيل ميسي في مباراته امام الاخضر لكن
حصل من لم يتمناه فيما تداول مغردون صورا
لمشجعين للمنتخب الارجنتيني وهم يستبدلون
قمصانهم بقمصان المنتخب السعودي بعد فوزه
بهدفين لهدف وتصدره للمجموعه الثالثه في
نهائيات كاس العالم بثلاث نقاط ثمينه اذا
في المجموعه في مجموعته هو
نبقى في اخبار مونديال قطر حيث عدد
المنتخب المغربي طموح جماهيره بالتاهل
للدور الثاني عبر المباراه التي انتهت
بالتعادل السلبي مع نظيره الكرواتي وصيف
بطل العالم ضمن الجوله الاولى من مباريات
الدوري المجموعات واستدع من جماهيري هائل
في استاد البيت بمدينه الخور تفوق اسود
الاطلس في اغلب فترات المباراه خصوصا في
الجانب الهجومي حتى انه كاد ان يحسم
النقاط ثلاث لمصلحته لكنه لم ينجح في هذه
الشباك رغم صناعه عدد من الفرص الحقيقيه
بعدما انهى تعاقده مع نادي مانشستر
يونايتد كشف كريستيانو رونالدو عن ساعه
جديده بقيمه 124 الف دولار لكنها تسببت في
موجه غضب على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
صوره الساعه التي نشرها رونالدو
وهو يحرز هدفا في شباك مانشستر يونايتد
اثناء لاعيبه لمصلحه ريال مدريد الاسباني
فيما ياتي رحيل الدون عن يونايتد بعد
مقابله تلفزيونيه مدونه اجرها الاسبوع
الماضي والتي قال فيها انه شعرا بالخيانه
من مسؤولي النادي متهم اياهم بمحاوله
الاطاحه به
وفي خبرنا الاخير افادت صحيفه واشنطن بوست
بان ثلث المعلنين الكبار في منصه تويتر
اوقفوا اعلاناتهم خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
صحيفه الامريكيه اوضحت ان نحو 35 معلنا من
الكبار اوقفوا اعلاناتهم المدفوعه بعد
سيطره ملياردير ايرون ماسك على شركه تويتر
مثيره الى ان مبيعات الاعلانات تمثل اكثر
من 90% من عائدات العصفور الازرق خلال
العام الماضي في مالجا ماسك الى فرض
اشتراك مقابل الحصول على علامات التوقيت
الزرقاء للحسابات لزياده ارادات الشركه
قبل ان يعلن عن ايقاف تلك العمليه مؤقتا
[موسيقى]